all right so to kick things off I feel
like I got a couple ways I can ask this
but I'm gonna go with more fun one why
archaeologists we were talking about how
much we loved the
archaeologist adventure genre
you're you're Indiana's Jones your
Nationals treasure
um Etc and the sort of you know
synonymification of the old you know
serialized
uh adventure stories basically
um and then started laughing about how
we were kind of fed the steady diet in
our youth of archaeologists being sort
of swashbuckling adventurers and how it
would be so funny to see a world where
that was actually the case
yeah devil busted just something you're
told uh once every few years when an
Indiana Jones movie comes out basically
so kind of going into that swashbuckling
thing I know this is not a show for kids
but it does kind of have that Saturday
morning cartoon Vibe so does that fit
into the
into the swashbuckle of it all I think
so I mean there's definitely a uh some
Nostalgia of it you know the
the ambulance Adventure 80s uh Saturday
morning cartoons for sure is something
that we love uh and we hoped to have
some of that influence in it for sure
yeah yeah just anything from like when
we were kids you know look yeah like
Indiana Jones uh like Goonies I mean
things beyond all your kids too but that
sort of has that feel I mean like I've
said this remember like Legend of Zelda
is this way too like where there's like
a whole world out there to explore and
it's full of mysteries and secrets and
hidden temples and stuff like that and
and you know you get older and you go
like oh no it's not clear like that or
whatever but and I wonder that you
haven't uh when you play those things or
when you watch those things as a kid is
just a world we wanted to set it in
we're like no that is the case in this
world it's filled with like curses and
Enchanted objects and hidden temples and
secrets and Mysteries and
um you know that just felt like a world
that felt like a lot of of fun to
explore and to put a bunch of like
insane unhinged characters like rip into
you know and to mentioned before the
National Treasure of it all I def
I definitely I'm gonna steal the
Declaration of Independence by Prim and
so I guess I'm not way off but
um I was wondering if you speak a bit
more about the character like the
inspiration for that sort of energy yeah
the Nick Cage maybe I mean yeah I don't
think rip would ever steal the
Declaration of Independence mostly for
legal reasons but um
but uh yes I mean there's obviously
influence uh in where the voice started
uh in from the cage impression
um and you know he also happens to have
started movies that were Indiana Jones
adjacent
um but
um that was the kind of speaking of the
first thing we were talking about of the
world being all about archaeologists and
them being celebrities and
and then building out the character of
rip and deciding like oh we like this
idea that he
can't let go of things and he collects
things and people and isms and old timey
lingo and
he's kind of stuck in the past and
clinging to the past and then all of a
sudden it was like well there's still
there the the hint of this voice there
but it's actually becoming its own thing
which was much more exciting to us but
speaking of some of the people
um Saltine is one of them his sidekick
who I absolutely loved um being so lucky
she's so fun I also found it was
refreshing because this kind of show I
guess when we were all younger the Robin
into rips Batman would usually be like a
young guy and I was wondering if the
intent to have her be a young woman was
something that came about look at the
casting or was that something you were
looking at from the outset it was there
for the outset because we wrote the
script well on spec uh before we had
pitched it and stuff and before anyone
else was attached
um so it was there from the beginning
but
I think we just you know we we probably
have a list like pages long of like
potential characters that could have
been in the show and just certain ones
we kept gravitating toward especially as
we started figuring out like well what
would an episode of this be
and I think just an important thing for
us was like we just want to make sure
everybody is funny on the show and we
don't want a and and not to denigrate
Inspector Gadget or something but you
know they feel like there's certain
shows from your childhood where you're
like there's a really funny doofus at
the center and then there's actually
like the assistant male or female who
kind of is the smart one who actually
saves the day and is like the boring
character in a way and and
um you know no shade did Inspector
Gadget
watch the title
um the cartoon or the live action movie
or the light I said yes yes yeah very
true but we were just like okay well
let's have you know we want rip to have
literally an assistant that's the her
position but who is funny and stressed
out and weird and eccentric in her own
right and and cast it with someone who
makes us laugh a ton and you know we
were so fortunate that that became neat
run and
she makes us laugh so much and Andy
image will record together sometimes and
uh you know find new things that aren't
in the script and it's been really fun
there is a massive voice cast in this
series like some of the best comedic
Talent out there but I'm like Curious
anybody in particular like really
surprised you when they kind of stepped
into record
that's a good question I mean in terms
of our primary cast
I would probably say Dale just because I
was aware of her from Origins the new
black but uh
not beyond that and her voice when just
when you hear her voice in a record
you're like oh man that is a perfect
animation voice yeah are you so resonant
and it has such personality and she has
great timing uh so I wouldn't say like
we were surprised she was good because
we knew she was good and it was more we
were just so happy that
it came to us that that idea came across
our desk and we got to hear it and
realize how cool it was yeah it
definitely helped the writing too like
as because we were writing before we
were recording but once we started
recording and hearing Dale's voice and
hearing her bring the character to life
it really
of that did the writing and we were able
to kind of write more toward what makes
her funny and makes Agatha funny so
different in
in developing like a scription animation
where it made me not not as easy to sort
of Riff Off of each other because you
are isolated in Boots like I know Mitra
and Andy record together sometimes but
that's not the case obviously for the
whole cast so I was wondering where the
difference in creating comedy and
animation comes in I mean there's a bit
there were sometimes even if it wasn't
like recording together like Andy would
be there like when we recorded Daniel
Radcliffe and stuff so Andy's not on a
live mic at that time but he's ripping
with Daniel Radcliffe a bit and so
sometimes it was just like we still were
able to capture the essence of feeling
like we're doing it live
um sometimes it's just me reading with
the other person uh and and but trying
to sort of you know not just go like
let's just record this line seven times
and then move on to the next like trying
to record a scene and get a little
rhythm going and
um having fun with that so
part of it was was we wanted it to feel
like kind of alive and and surprising in
the way that we recorded it
um but then invariably you do you know
record
a bunch of different sessions and have
to edit them together and that's just
where like
animation and our great editors and and
uh the animation process I mean to say
like really helps us kind of shape it
together and pick in different takes and
one seems good on its own and then you
hear what it's coming off of and you go
actually maybe not everything the other
one that does sounds like this and you
know it's just a lot of it's just the
process but it's been
great that we have some pretty awesome
people we're working there um so the two
of you have worked together before on
Brooklyn Nine-Nine but what has it been
like to collaborate together or kind of
build something from the ground up like
starting fresh like that whole
experience I mean it's been awesome I've
known Neil a while I think he
we first met when I was hosting the MTV
Movie Awards uh and awkward man brought
him in because he also has a
worked on Comedy Bang Bang forever which
is one of my favorite things ever
obviously one of the silliest things
ever created
um so we worked on that and then became
friendly and
I had been on bang bang a bunch of times
and we worked together on that and then
when I hosted the Emmys he basically ran
that with me and wrote incredible stuff
and then he worked on Brooklyn after
that so we we've known each other a long
time and collaborated a ton
and
the the reason we were so kind of hot to
do something together is because we have
such similar sensibility like we want to
go for the dumbest joke possible don't
want to shy away from that we think it's
to be celebrated and
we make each other laugh so you know
when we're working together on Brooklyn
which was super fun unto itself
um we kept talking about wanting to make
something uh new together and we talked
a lot about how much we love adult
animation and all the shows that it had
inspired Us in that world and
we kept talking about how we wanted to
make something where you know no matter
what the joke was if we were in charge
we wouldn't have to cut it
[Laughter]
and that is Digman essentially so
something that struck me about this show
is
awareness of like archaeologists taking
something from its home displaying it
somewhere else and that is rightly a
huge conversation right now
um
so I'm guessing that was approached
intentionally and it just kind of pop up
in the writing like oh right that's what
they do for a living like that was very
intentional when we were at the pilot
the the sort of line that's in there I
will never think about the consequences
you know that line was because we were
one of our first conversations about
doing a show like this was
talking about like hey it's not so cool
what Indiana Jones is doing that's
probably something you should be rooting
for uh and so having an awareness of
that as we write it you know and
as we came up with the character Ernest
we wrote The Pilot was was part of it
and it kind of Ebbs and flows in our
narratives of like
some of the episodes have absolutely
nothing to do with
rip and the and the crew being put on
jobs that even raise that question like
the ethics don't become a part of it
um but obviously from the outset we
wanted to not act like we were oblivious
to the fact that it's a complicated
yeah we've really smart and funny
writing staff and priority number one
was always being as funny as possible
and feeling something of jokes but it
doesn't mean we didn't also then
sometimes have conversations but all
right what are we saying here is this
something we should be rooting for
should we tweak this to you know change
things like how what what are we saying
here so it was just part of the process
was like let's first of all try to be
funny we're not trying to like write an
essay we're trying to be funny and then
but then you know having to take
responsibility for what you write and
having those conversations and sometimes
things would change and sometimes you
know be like all right I think we on
betraying our values here and so
worked out so speaking of the show
generally
um were there any like episodes
characters Concepts like like
non-spoilery that really took you by
surprise as you were developing it and
as you were writing it I mean once we
hire you know when we were pitching the
show we kind of had a bunch of different
ideas and one of them was like
they break the Ten Commandments and then
that the world is thrown into chaos
because they think that means you don't
need to follow them anymore and so that
was like an idea Andy and I had from
the moment we were pitching the show
yeah and then we hired a writing staff
and they brought in a bunch of uh really
funny ideas too and a lot of a bunch of
it just sort of came out of the room and
I couldn't even pinpoint a moment it
would happen but like sort of all the
twists with in in the third episode with
uh
when they're seeking the Commandments
and and who they the backup set and all
those twists and tyrions with with the
with the creatures uh have come into
he's so vague and not spoil anything you
know that wasn't something I don't think
Andy and I would have thought of as we
were pitching the show and just sort of
came out of like following the story
where I took us and felt like a fun
surprise and
the sixth episode has a big uh
has a big
kind of
object they're seeking that that was
pitched in the room by one of our
writers and just made us laugh a ton and
yeah so are there any ask this feels
like an archeology conversation I'm
sorry are there any
ideology or exploration like not
necessarily the technical but like the
pulpey action adventure side of it that
you maybe would want to explore that you
didn't get a chance to this season I
think uh
not in any specific terms but the reason
we were excited to make the show is that
it can feel like
how these like you know
Global adventure movies feel now where
we could be like but they could go
anywhere you know like like so
we could just think of places on Earth
or like any place for mythology that has
ever been alluded to on Earth and if we
feel like that's something we want to do
an episode about we can we can go for it
so
I don't think there's like one thing
where like oh man we did get to do that
we have to do that but it we already
have a crazy long list that would last
us many seasons of things that we think
would be fun jumping off points yeah
just other worlds you know countries
terrain cities just like a lot of the
fun a lot of times was like we come up
with something in our animators once we
see the designs we're like oh my God
they make Venice look so awesome or they
make uh you know London looks so awesome
or something like that and it's just
like I would love to see them do that
with so many other places around the
globe and and and and also fictional
places as well so
um you know there's a lot of there's a
ton I'd be so excited to go explore and
and dig into the archeology of other
places unintended yes this is out here
um so Andy I want to Pivot for a second
and ask this is kind of a two-parter but
um
I need to ask about the Lonely Island so
first I want to know if you guys have
anything coming up anytime soon uh if
you mean something where it's all three
of us making something solely together
with just the three of us sadly the
answer is not right now yet
but
we share our company so kind of
everything all of us are doing is sort
them together but I know that's not what
the question actually is
um but I'm hoping soon it's been really
hard with
kids living on different coasts covid
shows movies
um
it's we're like turning into a Trope of
Comedy groups it's like getting pushed
apart in their old age
oh we we really want to make another
album we really want to make another
movie together we're constantly talking
about how and when that could happen so
I would say 100 well it just isn't in
the immediate and then I guess this ties
back into dig man and if this is the
spoiler that's fine
um I can take it out but can we expect
any musical moments from Red Pikmin oh
it's nothing in the pilot so it's a
little on the pilot you get a little
what a jazz man he's a bit of a Jasmine
and uh yeah they have Tim Robinson
singing so that's in the end of the
beginning of the fourth episode
uh the trailer we just put out with with
the smash the the slowed down Smash
Mouth we demanded be doing the singing
But ultimately decided against it so not
yet it's a lot like a Lonely Island
question seems to be a couple that it
will happen but it hasn't has not yet
and I will just leave that there for
everybody to dig into and that's my
terrible archeology joke for the day
okay great love it
um last non-digman question again Andy I
want to ask about your upcoming movie
Lee with children
you know it's a bit more of maybe a
serious thing than your fans are used to
saying from you and I just wanted to
know what that what that experience was
like uh it was really fascinating and I
had a great time
um we shot in Budapest
um and it's by far the most dramatic
project I've ever been a part of was The
Bachelor filming there when you were
there
The Bachelor The Bachelor went to
Budapest this season so I don't got it
no I wasn't aware of that all right
maybe they were I don't know
I know they were shooting Dune too
then you're gonna pop up in the bathroom
and be like what's that I wish
monthly so much
um
it was it was a really
amazing experience you know uh the a big
part of the draw for me outside of the
fact that I was really drawn to playing
this real person uh Danny Sherman and
the script was getting to work with Kate
Winslet who is someone that I just
really admire and I know has an
incredible work ethic and a consistent
high quality of work so
um when they asked if I'd be interested
in that that was for me a big reason I
was willing to give it a shot and sort
of go out of my comfort zone
um I haven't seen it yet so I don't know
how much I am or am not even in it
the block could be a little could be a
medium amount
um those options are all on the table so
then
uh but it was it was cool I mean I mean
it was really heavy and intense and I
feel like it's something I would not
have been ready for
even a few years ago in terms of my life
experience to be able to let my guard
down that much and be that
uh kind of grounded and real and and
vulnerable to it because it really
covers some heavy things
um but I'm glad I did it and I can't
wait to see it and I hope it turns out
great all right back to dig man back to
the archeology what is something the two
of you are really excited for fancy
experience with Ethan oh man I mean the
hope with this one truly and it sounds
kind of basic but it's just our thing is
we just hope people really laugh you
know we we went into it being like let's
let's go in with the intention of making
something that people who genuinely love
comedy can turn it on and just crack up
and hopefully like quoted with their
friends or something you know like the
sort of the back to the
the reason we got into this and you know
when we were first talking about doing
it we were like
so I've done this crazy sort of sketch
format with SNL and Lonely Island stuff
Neil has done it with bang bang and now
we both got a ton of narrative episodic
experience with Brooklyn Nine-Nine and
now we want to do something where we
sort of marry the two
uh the two skill sets basically yeah
um so so we're hoping that that's
how it lands yeah I mean honestly every
episode feels different and special in
its own way to me and uh there's not
like
uh um
I don't feel like it follows one strict
formula and they there's something in
every single episode I'm excited for
people to see and uh yeah there's little
moments where I
you know resonate with people the way
they make me laugh just like the end of
104 or something that the cold open of
the finale it's like there's just things
here and there that really make me
tickle me or make me laugh and uh I'm
excited for people to see all of them
yeah all right couple of rapid fire
things to end it out so favorite pulpy
non-indiana Jones non-national treasure
story that's sort of in this genre yeah
like sort of the archeology pulpey
Adventure genre
and it can't be big man either
we would never be so bold
you know I I don't know I mean I've I've
said earlier there's
um
like
John Houston maybe the man who would be
king us and
it's handy earlier like that's one that
kind of inspired a little bit like the
pilot and stuff like that that I think
is really interesting but in terms of
like
you know what I love is the South Park
like multi-part episodes where it's like
a huge Adventure like the imagination
land or the Black Friday like those like
that's what I love is like comedy and
they are just doing some huge genre
adventure thing and I think that really
tickles me a lot I mean there's
obviously also like the mummy movies and
I haven't seen them since I was a kid
but I really loved like Jewel of the
Nile and Romancing the Stone
and those are kind of like romance
action adventure where I feel like one
of them was at least a professor or
something but I could be
yeah
I mean like Yojimbo or something is
great too you know just like it's funny
and crazy and stuff yeah so bringing it
back to everybody's favorite whip
cracking archaeologist second of course
Thrift Dickman um Indiana Jones what is
your favorite Indiana Jones moment
do you have one I mean there's too many
to choose from but I will say
one that really shaped my life was when
the guy is doing all the crazy stuff
with the knives and then he shoots them
where you're like and I I know now for
reading about it that that was like they
wanted to choreograph a huge fight scene
and I think it was Harrison Ford was
like why don't I just shoot him it's
just funny because then you're
watching it he was like Ah that's just
the Indiana Jones franchise and in one
moment right there is like
you're get you're pulling something off
that's both like super funny but also
fun you feel like you're really on an
adventure but just the fact that they
were able to get such a huge laugh in
something that was so broad was really
impressive I thought um when I was a kid
I saw Indiana Jones the Last Crusade in
the movie theater and you know the guy's
face melts are kind of Ages rapidly at
the end
um and then that night I had a nightmare
where uh a skull said to me how old are
you I'm 99 and then a bit in my ear and
then I woke up and I hear her so
um
my mom and the Last Crusade giving me a
nightmare every every uh the the face
melting at the end of Raiders
I gave everyone nightmares yeah like I
don't know anyone that didn't have
nightmare that and maybe large margin
peewee and they'll be claymation which
is so funny to think about now when you
watch it it's so goofy
but like
I wonder if they feel like any
responsibility from that I feel like
every kid in in the world had nightmares
about that I think they do because
Crystal Skull did not have jump scares
like that so they're like okay we're not
taking responsibility for this
generation now we traumatized the whole
other one well thank you both so much
congratulations on the show um all right
well thank you both yeah thank you so
much